Speaker 1: Today we're going to be speaking
with Lillie Geismar, who's an associate professor
of history at Claremont McKenna College and
also author of the book Left Behind the Democrats
Failed Attempt to Solve Inequality. Really
great having you on today. I appreciate your
time.
Speaker 3: Oh, thank you so much for the invitation.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, I think an interesting
place to start or a logical place to start
would be most of my audience, I'm sure, would
agree that at least the rhetoric and the promises
of the Democratic Party relative to the Republican
Party would seem more likely to reduce inequality
and to sort of level the economic disparities
that we see in the United States. And yet,
to a great degree, it really hasn't happened.
And we could talk about why that's the case.
We could say, well, it's it's despite every
good intention, it's simply Republican obstructionism
and sort of shift the blame elsewhere and
and take that approach. But you take a different
approach in the book. Can you talk a little
bit about the way you see what you call that,
this failed attempt to deal with inequality?
Speaker 3: Absolutely. And I think that one
of the issues which you've identified and
is not and this is not to say that the Republican
I think the Republican Party is blameless
in efforts to address inequality. But I think
so often there's an effort to just sort of
say this. It's all about putting putting blame
solely on the Republican Party for its policies.
And one of the things I really wanted to understand
is that why inequity has increased so dramatically
in the United States since the since the 1970s,
but especially since 1990. And to understand
the Democratic Party's efforts to address
it and why those efforts didn't work. And
what I came to largely is the fact that the
Democratic Party, increasingly, starting in
the 1970s, started to use try to use the private
sector and the market as a tool to address
inequality. And what I want to understand,
one, to understand and what the book addresses
is, is why those kinds of programs don't work
or why that approach actually led to shrinking
the social welfare state and compounding inequality
and really contributing to many of the kind
of problems we are seeing today.
Speaker 1: Yeah, because so can you give us
like one example that might be an easy, easily
relatable one in terms of the idea of how
to use the private sector, what was done and
why it did not work.
Speaker 3: Well, there's a the book sort of
talks a bunch of them. Yeah. One of the really
clear ones is the efforts to use programs
like micro-enterprise or microfinance, which
is this very popular tool in especially the
1990s and really beginning in the 1980s, people
like Bill Clinton had the idea. So for those
of you who aren't familiar with what microenterprise
is, it's the idea of kind of giving small
loans to poor people to start their own businesses.
And so you start sort of micro entrepreneurs.
It was first experimented with in the global
south, especially in Bangladesh, by someone
named Muhammad Yunus. And the Clintons in
Arkansas in the eighties become really enamored
in this with this program and that that you
could kind of take what's a private sector,
a tool of micro, of entrepreneurship and starting
your own business. And that could actually
be a replacement for traditional forms of
welfare and particularly forms of of of kind
of cash assistance. So that's what Bill Clinton
touts. And the idea is that, I mean, it removes
the kind of social safety net and leaves leaves
poor people up to the kind of whims of the
market. So the way it was sold is kind of
like turn your hobby into a business so you
can instead of needing sort of the support
of government, you can kind of be your own
entrepreneur. And that's one kind of program
that was adopted. I can give a couple other
examples, too, but this idea of another one
would be kind of turning to there's in terms
of housing, the the program which comes out
as Hope six, which is which is a public private
mixed income program. So taking away like
the kind of big public housing program, big
public housing developments in Chicago, them
the most iconic ones are Cabrini Green or
the Robert Taylor Homes in Intent. And instead
turning to these more kind of kind of townhouse
style developments that can kind of earn a
profit and well, at the same time that will
help people. And so that's another kind of
approach that that comes in that is addressing
this kind of critical problem of housing,
but in a way that's kind of using the private
sector. The book also looks at things like
charter schools as a key example of this,
too, which is a kind of mechanism using the
mechanisms of the market. So it charter schools
though at least have a Democratic Party in
the nineties promoted. It was not about making
a profit but was about using the techniques
of the private sector to make make public
schools more efficient and accountable. And
so all of those are kind of efforts going
to address these what what traditionally all
of those welfare, housing, schools. The idea
is that those are kind of critical components
of of what the public sector should be doing.
And we rely on government to do. And instead,
you're kind of taking mechanisms of the private
sector to do that.
Speaker 1: And it seems, at least in some
cases, when these mechanisms are initiatives
are created, it's also used as a as a justification
to cut other programs. And it seems that it
ends up being sort of zero sum in a sense.
Speaker 3: Yeah, that's I mean, I think that's
absolutely right. And so one of the things
I look at the book is there's a lot of this
language of these are win wins. Yeah. Because
in a lot of this a lot of the ideas is that
it's and another kind of critical program
that I look at is like efforts to kind of
turn treat poor communities like their parts
of the global south and to kind of bring corporate
investment to them. So like the same way that
globalization was working internationally,
these were bring private sector investment
and that's like helps the community the brings
jobs brings Walgreens. But at the same and
also helps companies like Walgreens gain a
profit. And so it's a win win but it's actually
in many ways a zero sum in the fact that like
who benefits in that in that mechanism is
the companies more than the kind of places
are people who live there.
Speaker 1: When I recently interviewed Gary
Stevenson, who's an inequality economist,
he said that of everything he's looked at
and studied extensively, that at the end of
the day, the most effective way to reduce
inequality is through government taxation.
Basically, a government deciding, here's how
we're going to use taxation. We're going and
you know, the specific policies are, of course,
to be discussed, but that that's really the
way to do it. Is your experience that that
is the most effective?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I think it's taxation coupled
with intense government spending and the spending
by the by the federal government and by state
governments into providing for people. So
the common and that is that's often achieved
through taxation of largely of the wealthy.
And that's a really important I mean, I think
because one of the ways that this this kind
of approach and so it really kind of comes
into fruition in the nineties under during
the Clinton ministration is this idea of and
the Clinton administration did enact some
some modest taxes on the wealthy but not I
mean, not to the full extent, but their idea
was really that you give corporations and
wealthy people that sort of opportunities
to help rather than actually making them make
any kind of real sacrifice. And that's kind
of what taxing a taxation approach would do
that would reduce inequality. And in those.
Times and make more funding of money available
to help people in need and serve, rebuild,
rebuild or have a vibrant social safety net.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, I think this next question,
it's sort of like an economics question, but
I think it's also a history question. And
of course, you can answer it in whichever
way you think is appropriate. When, when,
when I hear sometimes some on the left who
they're not taken super seriously in most
cases, but they talk about a 73% marginal
tax rate or a 78 on really, really high incomes.
I understand the math of it, and I understand
the studies about government revenue is maximized
when you have that top tax rate at about 73%.
And I get it. But it also seems completely
politically infeasible right now. And also,
there's this major issue of no matter what
the rates are, there's lots of ways to get
around paying anything at all and deductions
and loopholes and the way businesses and other
things are used. So from a from a historical
perspective, in terms of what's viable and
what's acceptable to populations, where do
you think the Democratic Party should be on
tax policy?
Speaker 3: Well, I think there is I mean,
I think what has been largely popular has
been this idea of and I I don't know the exact
I can't do the exact numbers. I was yeah,
I'm terrible at math. I don't know if you
or anyone else the wrong impression. But I
think that one of the things that comes up
with that is that actually I do think that
that message of that that corporations and
wealthy people should be held responsible
and should not be kind of. And that goes with
both sort of what they're paying, but also
that those loopholes need to be closed. And
I think that that actually has been a really
popular message both and you saw it in Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren's campaigns.
And I think that that actually that has bipartisan
appeal to some some degree. So that is a popular
message. I think when it's when you get into
the numbers, probably that it's more it's
more complicated. I think one of the issues
that goes to this, too, is that you would
actually need with that corporate closing.
Things like the corporate corporate loopholes
and various other things is that actually
goes to regulation. And that's another kind
of critical piece. And so I think one of the
things I looked at in the book is the ways
in which so much of and this goes to a kind
of thinking about what Republicans and Democrats
have done. That especially during the Clinton
era, there was so much deregulation of the
financial of the financial and tech sectors,
and that really contributed to some of these
kinds of inequalities, too. So it's both in
terms of regulation, in various different
capacities that actually do force corporations
to pay more of their share. That is a way
of kind of addressing some of these kind of
major structural inequities that exist.
Speaker 1: It also seems that sometimes it's
not I don't want to say it's difficult, like
people don't have the cognitive capacity,
but it's just people are busy and they have
lives. And so the idea of, well, let's raise
taxes on the rich. Okay, right. But usually
that means income taxes and the very rich
often don't pay income tax because they're
earning money through other means. Okay, well,
then let's raise capital gains. Rate is like,
okay, well, you can do that. But then instead
of selling stock, you can pledge the stock
as collateral for a loan, which is another
mechanism that's used. And it's not that people
can't understand these things, but it's most
people aren't, you know, buried in these things
day to day because they're working and so
on and so forth. It seems that that also is
sort of a difficulty, even when a solution
is proposed, that isn't really a solution
like just raising income tax rates. So there's
a communication aspect to this.
Speaker 3: Yeah, absolutely. And I think that
there's a that's a really important point.
This is these are really complicated things.
And the kind of mechanisms that are used are
hard to understand or don't sort of distill
down to a soundbite. And so you can lose.
I mean, you can your eyes glaze over. It just
doesn't make any sense. And it doesn't seem
like it's affecting day to day life in very
severe ways, I think for the average kind
of the average person. And I think the other
kind of piece of that, too, is the ways in
which. So I think this goes to the way we
think about inequality. And this also goes
back to like sort of in my book, I look primarily
at the kind of this period of the nineties
when there is kind of large economic growth.
If we look back in the nineties with some
nostalgia of this period of like and so that's
that's one of the things that happened, I
mean, is that you have overall economic growth,
but inequality increasing. And I think the
other kind of key piece of that is taking
away these components of the social safety
net and sort of turning to the private sector
in the market to solve those problems created
a creates a system of profound kind of vulnerability
and and predation by corporations. So that's
sort of some of the kind of the products of
some of these these issues, too, coupled with
huge amounts of private, personal, private
wealth being amassed over the nineties. But
in these with other kinds of mechanisms such
to use them and I will go back to saying I
don't think this was just this is just that
all of this falls solely on the Democratic
Party. I think we're the Republican Party.
And the end, particularly the doors of the
Bush administration, played a really important
role in kind of widening a lot of these kinds
of policies. But I do think it's really important
to understand where the Democrats have been
complicit in many ways and and pushed them
in in different avenues.
Speaker 1: Yeah. Bill Clinton, you've mentioned
Bill Clinton a couple of times, and Bill Clinton
will often get a arguably deserved amount
of blame for this, but also, I mean, 1994
and Newt Gingrich coming in to the House of
Representatives and that huge push for deregulation
and so on and so forth. And then George W
Bush as well, precipitating the 2008 recession.
There seems to be a lot of blame to go around
here.
Speaker 3: I think totally. And so that's
one of the things is that sort of in trying
to kind of pass some of that out and to sort
of understand and the other thing that I really
tried to do in my book, which I think is also
really important, are are twofold. One is,
is understanding what the Democrats will give
people like Bill Clinton, any other kind of
new Democrats of the Democratic Leadership
Council, what they believed and what they
did. And that and also that those are not
sort of indistinguishable from the Republican
Party, that there are actually distinctions.
And in the kinds of policies and the reasons
for why Democrats versus Republicans pursue
particular ideas, and that there was a genuine
belief that stimulating the private sector
and stimulating certain forms of of new economic
growth and tech finance and trade would be
a way to address create forms of social equality.
And but that's not what played what ended
up happening. And so that's really what I've
tried to understand through my through my
work.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to ask about
often when I ask folks, what is the model
of a country that has sort of done this correctly?
Usually you hear countries in Northern Europe
or Denmark, Sweden, Norway, etc., and everybody
just kind of shrug their shoulders and, you
know, stop talking about it. Are those actually
the models? Are there models? Are there successful
examples to look out of?
Speaker 3: I don't think so much. Borgen And
I.
Speaker 1: Think that's a great show. Yeah,
I'm watching this new season. It's great,
it's great.
Speaker 3: And I strongly recommended it.
But imagine I was like, This is incredible.
Yeah, no, I think I mean, I think that those
are always the places. But I think the really
important thing about that, I mean, when I
look at those places is they're really homogenous.
And traditionally and so where social we sort
of look to these these European countries
as kind of the as the kind of Mecca, but they've
had huge issues and tensions over immigration
and sort of who is part of their social of
their social welfare. And I think that's actually
a really another critical piece of the United
States is the ways in which inequality sort
of becomes kind of commercial questions of
of of race and how that operates and sort
of who is worthy of certain kinds of assistance.
And so I do think that many, many Western
European countries are also experiencing the
same kinds of questions today. But I do think
the ways in which they have the commitments
to social spending and to having a kind of
robust social safety net and social welfare
is is critical. I know because I know you've
mentioned the viewers, but your that you were
just a baby. And when you look at the kind
of differences of what what parental and child
child care are in many in many Western European
countries, it's like it's astounding. Yeah.
The difference of United States. So on those
levels, I do think there is and that does
that does contribute to forms of inequity
of sort of fundamental inequity in that state.
So I do think that there is a place and I
mean, Denmark is a country of 6 million people,
so we shouldn't all move there. Right. I do.
Speaker 1: It's like a state in the U.S.,
basically. Yeah. Yeah. The book is Left Behind
The Democrats Failed Attempt to Solve Inequality.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
a professor of history at Claremont McKenna
College. Lily Geissler, really appreciate
your time today.
Speaker 3: Oh, thank you so much for having
me on.